Ámbar Reyes: Um, so welcome,
everyone. For those. For those
of you who don't know, I'm
Heather Hendershot, Director of
Graduate Studies and comparative
Media Studies at MIT. So great
to host this talk today with
Jorge Caraballo, who is a
journalist and a 2022, Harvard
Nieman Fellow. Before that he
worked for four years as the
growth editor at Radio
Ambulante, the most popular
documentary podcast in Spanish,
and the only one in that
language distributed by NPR.
There he led online and offline
engagement initiatives to grow
the community around the
podcast, he holds a master's
degree in media innovation from
Northeastern University. He is a
Fulbright scholar and a Google
News Initiative fellow. And the
title of his talk today is How
to Use Audio Storytelling to
Cultivate a Community and Keep
It Engaged. So I will pass the
floor over to Jorge now.
Jorge Caraballo: Thank you,
thank you so much, Heather,
Andrew, for inviting me and very
happy to be here. I will share
my screen I have a presentation.
So let me go back because I have
to share some to share a sound
okay. So I No need to go deeper
on this. This is my this is my,
my baby. I worked four years as
the growth editor at Radio
Ambulante. And yes, I was my
mission was bringing more people
in into the podcast, more
listeners have grown the
audience that was like a main
metric. But another metric of
success was creating the
environment. So people would
participate. People would use
Radio Ambulante as a centerpiece
for civic conversations, and
making the most impact out of,
of, of our journalism. So I was
constantly using the stories
which were, which are episodes
of 30 minutes, 45 minutes, every
week, to all over Latin America.
Radio Ambulante little bit of
context is a podcast, it's like
This American Life in Spanish,
that's how you can make an idea
of what it is. And every week,
every Tuesday, we like we
present an episode. And that
episode, my goal was to make it
was to make it as impactful as
possible, and impactful by our
standards was making it create
conversations all around the
continent. So that was my job.
And what I what I what I want to
do in this in this presentation,
is to show you some examples of
how we did that, like what kind
of engagement exercises we did
and why. Just like a little bit,
making you see how we cooked the
dish. And then some principles
that I think can be replicated
by anyone that is interested in
using storytelling. And this
could be of course, documentary
as we did nonfiction, but also
it could be fiction. And it
doesn't matter necessarily that
these are audio stories to me.
What this what I learned in
Radio Ambulante is that just a
good story can be used to bring
the attention of the internet of
people on the internet and make
it a platform to connect people
among each other and to create a
common purpose to to get to know
ourselves and to get to know
others. So that's that I'm going
to go step by step through those
for those principles, and then
we can have a q&a. So let's
start with this So what you saw
there is a video or raw video on
edited of Radio Ambulante Zoom
party when the pandemic started,
and the spirit of our community
was in the lowest level, we were
like, we need to do something to
remind ourselves that we are not
alone, that this is not a
podcast that is talking to
individuals necessarily, but
that this podcast is a platform
of a community that is
distributed all over a
continent, in Latin America, in
Europe, in the United States,
there are around 90,000 people
listening to this podcast every
week.
Unknown: And we can do something
to remind that if you listen to
Radio Ambulante, you share some
things, some features with other
people who also listen to Radio
Ambulante. And we can celebrate
even though this is a tough,
tough moment in our life, we can
celebrate that we're not alone.
And let's just do a party, we
assume let's see what happens.
And we did that. So what is what
was the first party and we did
four of them. And to each of
them more than 1000 people
attended. And they were, as you
see here, they were turning
their cameras on. They were
showing a their pets, their
customs, their children, they
were showing you their living
room, they were showing you
their life. And it's still to me
impressive that people trust it
so much, right? We are all aware
of how the internet is a place
in which you need privacy,
because you don't know what are
the intentions of those who you
are interacting with, with. But
in this community in this
community, even though most of
these people don't know each
other at all. And they're very
different backgrounds and
countries and cultures. They
share something there are
listeners of Radio Ambulante.
And because of that they trust
each other. But this is not
something that happened out of
the blue, this is not something
that was like a random idea.
This was a conclusion. This was
the consequence. This was a
consequence of an effort of
cultivating a community around
storytelling. So there are other
examples of these kinds of
interactions between strangers
that listen to rival data. This
is a picture of our listening
club. And we will talk about
later like strangers in their
cities, getting into a place
where they listen to an episode
and then have conversations
civic conversation. Or this is
our this is a picture of our
team in 2018 when we did a, a
live show in New York and
Washington DC, or. Yes, other
examples that we're going to I
am going to describe what how we
have done it. Because I think
that it's it's important that we
remember that the internet is
not only that corporative
platform in which this big
corporations are giving you some
leverage to communicate with
others. But the internet is also
a network in which you can
create trust. And to do that
stories, I think, are one of the
main main things. We're one of
the main channels to connect
people in a way that they trust
each other and create together.
So I'm going to describe you how
we did that. But I think that
this can be translated to many
different contexts not only in
podcasts, but in other ways,
other creative ways, other
creative languages. So I'm going
to show you some examples of our
engagement and you will be able
to listen a little bit of these
of the stories that I am
blanketed. By the way disclosure
when I came to as a Nieman
Fellow, I stopped working at
Radio Ambulante so this is a
sample of what we did in the
four years that I was there. So
the first one is it's a an
exercise that we did when we
publish an episode all
ÁlbumDeMigrantes or Migrants
Album, I'm going to show you but
you're going to listen a short
clip and then we'll give you
more context about the story.
Spanish Speaker: [Speaker in
Spanish.]
Unknown: So migration is a big
theme in Latin America. And in
the recent years, in the last
five years, Venezuela migration
to other countries in the
region. It's a big story. So
what do you just listen is an
amid an American is Venezuelan
woman who migrated to Peru. And
it was very hard for her to
adapt to this new country, not
only because she faced
xenophobia, but also because of
what she just said, like,
everything changes so quickly,
and you're still so attached to
your country that you need to be
living in that unstable
situation of should I have roots
in the new country? Should I
root myself here? Where should I
be prepared to move to another
place? What do I do? Like where
do I belong? And one of the main
characteristics of Radio
Ambulante or or one of the big
groups in inside the Radio
Ambulante community is that of
migrants, many of Radio
Ambulante listeners are people
who have migrated from Latin
American countries, to the
United States to Europe to other
places, a in which they find new
opportunities. So we knew that
many listeners of Radio
Ambulante shared kind of a
similar story, or have, have had
led an experience similar to
that point of [..]. So we try to
do something we try to tap into
that collective knowledge and
experience inside our community.
And ask them to give an Anamer
advice, or give Anamer some
words of recognition and
awareness of what she was going
through. So we treated this like
as Anamer, our, like this main
character of today's episode,
many of the people that listen
to them a lot, they know what it
means to be Anamer. So share a
story, a short story about your
experience, establishing
yourself in a new place, what
was the hardest thing or the
most exciting thing, and we use
it this hashtag. And this thing
exploded. We started getting
these kinds of responses. More
than 10 years ago, I haven't
left. I haven't lived in
Argentina, where I was born. I
left I live in Puerto Rico and
then I met friendship there and
disgrace. Now we live in Bogota,
where their son kisses me and
I'm a drowned by books that
don't let me go. And here I
understood that to be a migrant,
can also be a nationality. And
then people started sharing
pictures. We didn't ask them to
share pictures, they started
sharing pictures of their first
years of being migrants, or this
guy who had like 3000 retweets,
which was very unusual in our in
our engagement strategy or
engagement work. He said, I got
four years ago here in Paris
with 200 error, euros, not
speaking French, not knowing
anyone. I started working as a
dishwasher. A and a year ago, I
brought my dad because my mother
died. And today I'm the chef of
a bar I speak French and I live
with my dad in an apartment and
he was using the hashtag and
this was very intimate stories
right of people who were somehow
reflect who who felt reflected
in our story but at the same
time we're proud of what came
after that turbulent first time
or first period as immigrants
one out and then people were
like acknowledging that a
podcast like she cello she's
saying when a podcast generates
that listeners a make their
universe bigger and multiply the
stories and this is what was
going on. And this is what I
think it's super super valuable
because I map story became the
first in a block of another
stories. And what was happening
here is that listeners were
making this story bigger, were
enlarging the story. Were making
it more complex. And the
paradigm of the first the way we
understand, we usually
understand our role as
storytellers is that we produce
the story, we publish the story.
And that's it, right? People can
comment the story, or can share
the story. But what is happening
here is that people are making
the story grow with old stories,
the episode didn't end, the
episode was not a discrete case,
when we publish it, the episode
was open. And
the continuation of the episode
is this is this. And I find
striking and beautiful to
understand storytelling as an
open ended process,
collaborative, and
participative. Right. So this is
what was going on with this
story. A, this person is sharing
what I have learned today, and
the stories in this hashtag,
have me crying, celebrating,
laughing, thinking about my
people. So that's just an
example of how the character of
a story. And this is a
nonfiction story is not alone.
Because you as a listener, you
are also a character of the
podcast. And we will get we're
going to talk more about that
next thing later. This is
another example. It's called Mi
Lugar de Siempre, my favorite
place. And it was about a story.
It was an exercise that we did
were ritual, as I will start
calling it this was a ritual
that we did. When we published
this story, the about a group of
friends in San Jose, Costa Rica,
capital of Costa Rica, this is a
group of college friends who
started gathering at this very
tiny, a dark karaoke bar in
downtown San Jose, this was a
bar that almost only them
attended, it was not the most
popular bar was not in not at
all, in the list of touristic
places in San Jose, it was like
a kind of secret corner of the
city, that they call it with
direct entities with their
joyfulness and they got to know
the the owner of the bar. And
unfortunately, and this is a
spoiler of the story. But
unfortunately, the owner of the
bar was this Chinese mysterious
Chinese woman decided to close
the place. And with that
decision, their life as a group,
like took a different direction.
So we decided to focus on
something that was like an
important line in this story,
which was these places that
become content or become vessels
of your identity, and are not
the most popular places in your
city. But I think we all we all
have that we all even though
even if we live in a city or in
a rural area, we all have these
kind of centuries, that are
relevant or to be expressed the
expression of our of our
identity of our freedom. And we
wanted to know, one more those
centuries. For our listeners, we
have listeners, as I told you,
everywhere in the world, mostly
in the United States, a South
America and Central America,
also in Europe. And we wanted to
know what were those centuries.
And not only to know that, but
to see them. And not only to see
them, but to make them useful.
So we ask people, what's your
favorite city in [...]? What's
your favorite place in the city
you live, not the most touristic
one, but the one that you love
most. Mention it using this
hashtag, MiLugarDeSiempre. And
we're going to make a map of
places that you cannot miss with
your recommendations. And we did
this. We got this we can't we've
got this kind of responses. So
she is sharing a place in Mexico
City in the biggest university
there. A or this one in Sierra
Leone, in Freetown, or this one
in Montreal is like a kind of
small cafe. We got this, we got
a lot of things. And then we
were like, Okay, let's make
something with this. And we
created a collaborative map. And
this is a very simple thing with
we created a collaborative
Google map. So anyone, instead
of sending tweets with pictures
could just create a pin in their
city and share it with others.
And the idea of this was to
create like a touristoic guide
of Latin America, a secret
places or more loved places by
listeners. So as a Radio
Ambulante listener, if you go to
Argentina, you will have some
options, or some places that are
relevant to listeners in
Argentina, if you go to Peru,
the same if you go to Colombia,
if you go to the US, then you
will have some reference of what
are those places are important
to other lists himself, right,
granted, and they are a
organized by categories. So
there were restaurants for jazz
clubs, there were these
bookstores, there were a also
karaoke bars,
a lot of stuff. And this is an
idea that it's very, like, easy
to replicate. And you could
spend a lot of time trying to
develop a map or like the lines
of code created in a fancy way.
But we were like, Let's use the
things that people use that are
simple to replicate and to make
this exercise, because we have
found that we can not ask, like,
we need to ask for things that
are not very time demanding, if
we will want this to be really
participative. And at the same
time, it needs to be useful. The
incentive for people to
participate is that this will be
useful for them. And for others.
If it's not like that they don't
they don't they don't engage. So
engagement like good practices,
just use the platforms that
people use. And Google Docs is
something that almost everyone
uses. Other way of engaging with
people and making stories live
beyond the limits of fun out
your story of an episode is like
this conversation prompts, and
we started using social media.
So this is a this is a question
that we asked in. Like five
months after the pandemic
started. This is September 2020.
A after the worst of the
quarantined, we ask people like,
hey, for those of you who have
little children at home, what
was the most memorable game
exercise or project that you
that you did with them during
work during part time. So these
were a lot of parents that have
been stuck in their apartments
or houses with children. And we
wanted to, we wanted them to
single out that memorable
moment, that memorable thing
that they did with their with
their children, because we had
done an episode about that we
had done an episode in which the
characters had done that. So a
lot of comments about that, or
this one was a one year after
the pandemic was clear. And we
asked for what's the best thing
that happened to you in a year
full of bad news. And at the
same time, like 200 comments. So
we were trying to make
conversations that were
improbable, and that we're not
just for the sake of having
comments, but of making people
think about those. Not I
wouldn't say positive things,
but things that are not usually,
in the mainstream narrative of
this was a terrible year, which
was, or this was a like, I only
I had no ideas of what to do
with my children, which is
through a but at the same time,
there were other stuff
happening. Right. And and we
wanted to focus on that and to
use the experience of the
community to have that
conversation happen. We also did
extra episodes with the
community and because of the
community, which is something
that most newsrooms that that
newsrooms, usually try to avoid.
Because when you open the doors
of your editorial newsroom to
your audience, then they will
start demanding, or that's the
that's a the fear of editors and
journalists is that they will
start demanding you to do what
they want, and interfering with
your creative or editorial
independence. But we were like,
Let's just not play that game
anymore. Let's just actually
listen, like people are
listening to us. Let's listen,
let's listen back is is the
minimum we can do like one of
the rules of the internet is
reciprocity. If this is a
network, it needs to be
reciprocal. So we asked people
what kind of stories they wanted
to listen to, and they voted a
like there was a big pool of
suggestions and pitches that
people sent. And they voted for
the stories that like all their
listeners sent that and then we
prioritize, and then we would
pick the winners. So
This is one of them like this is
an episode that we did for a
story about trends to call in
Argentina that for those girls
that was declared in trends in
in, in the country, a, and we
did a story like that was it was
story the story of this girl who
didn't identify with her with
the sex that she was born when
when that sex she was born. So
we did a story of a okay, this
is a story of a five year old
girl. And it's very emotional.
And we get to listen to the
mother and to a country that is
debating if should be record,
like legally recognized or not.
But the story ends with the girl
which she's just seven years
old. And we wanted to know, what
was the experience of those
listeners in triangularity? who
identify themselves as
strengths? And are not kids
anymore? What's this? What's
their story? Want to see? What?
What will be the life of this
girl in 10, 15 years? And to
answer that question, we asked
listeners Radio Ambulante that
in the [...], we did an extra
episode. Or we did this one. And
this one was suggested by the
community like we want to know,
what's the story in managing,
which is my city, the city where
I was born? What's the story in
Medellin with narco tours,
because there is something
happening in this city. And this
is like our listeners and this
idea. There are people coming
from all over the world, so
managing to visit the places
where Escobar lived, or the
places where he where he had,
where he put bombs. And I wonder
why are they doing that? What
What can what's the city how's
the city dealing with that?
Trouble past? So because I was
there as a reporter, I did a
story about Escobar and I did
one of these tours that took me
to her [...] to to his town,
that took me to the place where
he was in jail to his building,
like a building that he built
that where he lived. And then I
was able to talk to one of the
guides of those tours to ask
them, Why are you doing this?
Like, why are you glorifying
this person who victimize so
many people. And it's a it's a
very, I think, powerful story to
touch the identity of a city.
And we did it, thanks to two
listeners who suggested it and
to other listeners who voted for
it. Or we did this one in which
we tell the story of Radio
Ambulante. So this is a meta
story. Like this is the story of
a podcast, we'll make stories.
That experience which is also
which became the most visited
episode of Radio Ambulante. We
also have fun interactions in
social media. And like, like,
for example, a question, those
who listen to podcasts when they
were in public transportation,
or in their cars during the
pandemic. When are you listening
to podcast right now. And there
are like 660 responses like this
is like podcasts are a medium
that somehow demands routines,
like you listen to your
podcasts, usually when you're
doing something that you
constantly do going out for a
walk, going to commuting, a
washing your dishes, whatever.
So now that the routines are so
messed up because of the
pandemic, like when are you
listening to them? Or another
question is, how would you
explain what a podcast is to
your grandfather, grandmother
without mentioning the words
radio and Internet? Because
we're all the time constantly
exploring? How do people think
about this medium? How do they
how do they relate with this
media, which is essential if we
want to be useful and deliver?
So we need to understand what
does this mean? So these kind of
questions we did them or another
one to grow and to expand the
network. We ask people like
mentioned a friend that doesn't
listen to podcast and tell us
apart a detail about that
person, her favorite movie or
soda call sign a secret,
whatever you want to tell us and
then we will respond to a reply
with the ideal episode for them
of Radio Ambulante. So they
started listening to our
podcast. So we were using data
from the listeners. And at the
same time we were referring, we
will we will try to hook those
referrals with a personalized
recommendation.
But our strategy engagement
strategy was not limited on the
to the stories we wanted also to
create an invite different new
environments to listen to
podcast. So the first one of the
one that I think I am very proud
of is listening clubs. We got
this tweet in 2017 November
2017. I arrived on Radio
Ambulante in August 2017. So a
little less than two months
before for like two months
before this podcast before the
street, and this is Diane Bellis
a designer. I didn't know her.
She says Radio Ambulante is more
than a podcast in our home. It's
family. It's what [...] and I
discuss on Wednesdays, it's what
my parents listened to well,
[...] Papa. And which means come
and help us to cut the potatoes.
And she has in parentheses
checkout to tablet next to
cutting board. So there, they
start cutting potatoes together,
a and they're listening to an
episode. And we were like, oh my
god, people are people are
listening to this. Together.
This is not like, one of the
assumptions that we had four or
five years ago is that podcasts
are a very intimate,
individualistic, medium, like
you listen to your podcast in
your headphones. And that's
something that it's speaking to
your ear and to your ear only.
And then started challenging
that that assumption. And we got
we start getting more and more
of these messages. Like then we
were seeing some colleagues at
work in lunchtime listening to
an episode and we were like,
Okay, this is something that is
happening. That's interesting.
And then we were like, how might
we need to tap into this
opportunity? Because maybe
podcasts are not necessarily
something that you should listen
to alone. So we created
listening clubs and I want you
to watch this three minute
video. [Speakers in Spanish.]
[Speakers in Spanish.]
so what what happened when we
open this, this is the video
that we publish at the
beginning, we had tested the
idea we did it in our in the
cities where Radio Ambulante
team members were, and we
moderated those conversations
and we like kind of calibrated
the model. And then we open it
up, and we asked listeners you
to like it. Now this is for you,
we will not, we will not be
organized listening clubs, it's
not part of our we don't have
the capacity to do this, like we
did this for you to do it. So if
you want to use it, here's
everything. And we publish them,
we gave them everything as as I
as I said at the video. And it
was incredible. And there have
been more than 250 listening
clubs organized by listeners in
more than 50 cities around the
world. This is a decentralized
model. This is a model that in
each of those was in clubs have
been, have been organized, all
the resources come from
listeners, and it's something
that people feel responsible for
accountable to each other. And
our friendships and things have
started because of this. So more
than 3000 people across the
world have gathered to listen
episodes together. This is the
this is one of the screenshot
that's crucial have a map of 75
listening clubs that happen on a
day when we watch our ninth
season, like listeners all over
the world organized and clubs to
listen to the first episode of
that season they incentive was
we're going to give you the
episode, we're going to send you
the episode before it's
published to the world if you
connect with others in your
community, and listen, Because
together, we create a website
and you can still access it at
listeningclubs.com in which you
can connect with other
listeners, which was the hardest
thing because yes, yes, I am in
Cambridge right now. And I want
to listen to an episode with
other people. But how do I know?
Where are they? So listeners
were able in this website to put
the event like and say hey, I
want to host this and other
listeners could see oh, there is
someone on campus who wants to
do this and they sign up. So it
was easier to connect. And we
started getting this kind of
pictures. So this is a this is a
listening club in Panama
strangers who connected through
blood and became friends. This
is the same in Mexico City. A
some people started, like
expressing their FOMO and this
is like someone like Hey, does
someone adopt me in a club like
for Puerto Rico and I can join
online when the pandemic
started. A this is a an [...] it
because when the pandemic
started, some clubs kept going
to cafes, it was safe to do it
but other people join online.
And this is a picture of the New
York listening club which has
met non stop or at least until
2021 met non stop since 2019.
Every week, while we were in
season. We also have done live
shows in which listeners go to,
to this places in which we tell
life stories. And it is a way of
connecting us directly with the
audience and to remember that
what connects us as a community
is storytelling and listening
and what they what best way to
do it and telling stories live.
So with it, we have done tours a
of that. And also another
innovation or engagement
strategy were these two parties
in which we invited people to
celebrate in a in a hormone in
our lives. And to remind
ourselves that this is a
community this is not a group of
individuals a network of
individuals but a community. So
we hire DJs best DJs a of Latin
American music and this is what
happened like people had fun
people once again expressed the
or yes indicated that prime
Volante is not an organization
there is not an institution that
that there is a thesis between
Radio Ambulante that they are
Radio Ambulante. And this is a
proof of that. So this is just
like some gifts of how these
parties went which is super fun.
A it's so diverse everyone We're
in. Like, I remember the first
listening club that I organized,
I almost cried for the emotion I
guess like, because it was
incredible to see people
together, strangers together
being so vulnerable. And I
remember when I did this first
party, it was like, oh my god, I
just can't believe how much
trust these people have on us, a
and how privileged we are to
have connected this community.
So a lot of tweets of
celebration of the influx, a,
they say, if I'm not faced the
biggest family and joyful family
in Latin America, we're the
host, Danielle says, as usual
that [...] the party assume is
life affirming. Yes, a lot of
tweets, just celebrating and
somehow affirming our culture
and the things that make us
together. The last thing that I
want to show us innovation is
loopback. We know that 20,
around 20% of Radio Ambulante
listeners are non Spanish
speakers who are learning
Spanish. So we partner with
technology company, and we
created this Luca, Luca is an
app that uses Radio Ambulante
stories to learn Spanish. So
Spanish learners can, at the
same time, discover Latin
America through documentaries,
audio documentaries, and learn
Spanish at the same time. So all
of those things that I have just
mentioned to you lead to
something that it's not the
goal, like we didn't do it
because of that, but at the same
time, it's it's, it's a natural
consequence. And it's also
necessary for this efforts to
keep going and that is
Deambulantes. Deambulantes is a
membership program of Radio
Ambulante so listeners can
become members and can start
donating in a regular basis to
Radio Ambulante. And in
exchange, they get some perks.
So they get the episodes before
they're published, they get some
stickers, they get some stuff.
But basically, it's not about
what they get back. But they
contribute to the community. So
we started invite people will
create it like this campaign to
make people join Radio
Ambulante. A. And before we
created this in 2019, this was
the budget of Radio Ambulante.
So 60% of the budget came out of
foundations grants 36% out of
NPR, which distributors the
podcast, it has a exclusive
distribution agreement. It gives
some money in exchange of that
agreement and 4% of donations of
listeners a one year after that
year and a half after that. This
is how it changes. So members
were giving 20% of budget.
That's a huge thing. Like that's
a huge revenue stream. We're an
organization a nonprofit
organization, because it means
that those who are organization
are serving are feel responsible
for the success of the
organization. They are members,
they're there, they're invested
in the success of Radio
Ambulante. So storytelling at
the end can lead like good
storytelling and, like honest,
authentic engagement can lead to
you being able to keep doing
what you love to do to keep
working on your mission in which
like, that is what's happening
to Radio Ambulante. So that's
what I wanted to show you
concrete examples. Now I will
just go through 10 basic steps
to build an engaged community
like what did I learn what did
we learn as an engagement in a
after doing those things that
you just saw? Right? So let me
just take 30 seconds of silence
because I know I've been talking
a lot so let's just 30 seconds
of just letting it in and I'll
start okay.
Jorge Caraballo: Okay
Before thinking about doing an
engagement strategy for anything
you do Like, you have a podcast,
use letter, you have
storytelling project, a
storytelling project, you have a
game, whatever you have, if you
want to open it up and you want
to invite people to participate,
you need to ask yourself this
question is for us. First is Why
do you want to do it? What's the
motivation? What are you
expecting out of it? Do one to
two engagements because you want
them to become members at the
end, or because you want to
expand the stories with the
knowledge that it's in the
community. Because you want to
have to trigger conversations
that are not happening, you need
to understand what what is your
motivation. And also if you have
the capacity to maintain it over
time, because what happens, what
usually happens is that
companies start companies or
organizations start investing in
engagement. And they start doing
these kind of prompts online and
asking people to participate,
but then they're overwhelmed, or
they're busy with other stuff.
And then, and they don't have
resources or attention to their
engagement efforts. And people
feel that they're used, that
they're exploited, that their
attention is just a resource
that the organization or the
individuals are a misreading. So
do you have the capacity to
maintain it over time to keep
listening to keep being to keep
devoting attention to those
words, speaking to you? How will
you measure success is another
important question. And it's
related to the first one, like,
will you rate it? Will you
measure success because you have
more comments in your social
media, more likes more shares,
more listeners, or you will
measure success? Because
conversations are super
meaningful? Or because you've
got to a mobilize 10 people, 10
strangers to gather in a cafe
and get to know each other?
Like, how will you measure
success? That's important, and
it varies a lot. It depends on
what's your focus? Are you
willing to listen actively?
Which is, which is like, the
that question, right? Because,
as I said, you know, like, we
know, each of us know, when we
are being listened. And I as an
engagement editor, I'm on social
media, a human being like I go
to social media, and it's very
easy for me to see when a
company or even a person and
influence or whatever, is asking
questions, just because they
want to show or perform, that
they're popular, and that
they're relevant in their
communities, not because they
really care about what they're
asking, or a you know that
because of the way they engage
with those responses, right. And
also, the last one is, what
communities are meaningful to
you? And this is a question that
I asked myself all the time, as
a citizen as me, like, what are
those communities are meaningful
to me? And why like, why is it
so important to me to
participate in this? A
conversation around X or Y,
like, why why? Why do I feel so
invested in this or that
immunity? Why I'm so why am I so
like, Why do I feel so engaged
in conversations around this or
that topic. Because those
communities that are meaningful
to you will give you will be a
reference to the communities
that you want to create, right?
That you want to that you want
to connect. At the end, you
don't create a community when
you connect. So the first
principle is defining your
mission. It's like, that's first
for like, stage one. It's like
how, what's your value? And how
do you articulate that value in
a narrative that connects with
people? And I, I usually think
about missions as as a
narrative. Like, if there is a
narrative, there must be a
conflict, right? What's the main
problem that you're tackling?
And after asking that, why you
should, why are you invested
there? Why are you interested in
that? Why What Why are you
prepared to lead in this in this
scenario, this environment? And
what's your plan? What makes
your approach effective and
unique? And who are your allies?
So in Radio Ambulante's mission,
for example, is to bring greater
understanding about Latin
America using audio
storytelling? That's it. Right.
And
that's, that bring greater
understanding about Latin
America and Latin and Latinos in
the West. It's something that
it's easy to connect with
because Latinos and Latinas that
we have been so affected by
stereotypes in outside Latin
America, and even inside Latin
America, that to bring greater
understanding means that we're
challenging those stereotypes.
And the way to challenge those
stereotypes is telling stories
that show complex characters
that live ordinary lives. But
they're complex, right? So that
complexity, which is in every
story of our mandate, is kind of
a symbol of what many Latinos
and Latinas feel that we just
need to, we want to be to be
seen as three dimensional human
beings and [...] in in some
environments. So when you see
someone who has a mission and
has the skills and a good plan,
like I belong to those, it's
easier for for listeners to
connect to that. And to see live
learn more, not only like, one
more podcast in your list, but
someone who's helping you to
advance that goal, that it's the
goal of that organization to
embrace a network mindset. We're
online all the time, right?
We're digital beings now. So
what are the communities that
are already engaged in
conversations around the issues
you cover? You need to you need
to diagnose? Who are those
people who are already
interested in those issues? And
how does the network structure
looks like how are they
connected? How many people how
how they behave? Like how the
information flows in those in
those networks. And then you
need to engage with those
actors. It's not about this is
me, I hold all the truth, I know
everything, listen to me, but be
humble and say, Hey, let's just
let's just collaborate like,
what are you doing this what I'm
planning to do? How can we work
together and adapt? Like, and
this is mostly in the
journalism, that's it, but like,
journalism is no a finished
product. It's not like, it's not
something that it's already done
when you publish it. But it's,
it's a process. And I think that
to understand yourself as part
of a process and not as a
product. A Yeah, not as a
production. Company, a helps a
lot to engage with people. So
this is the mindset of the of
the productivity factory, and in
which things are just only
directional. And in networks,
it's like something that it's
going on, and it's flowing in
many directions, and it's
connecting you with many
anymore. It's not one to many,
but many to many a go to know
get to know those who share your
purpose. So now that you have
diagnosed were those who are
already interested in what
you're doing, like get to know
them, like, where are they?
Where your listeners listen to
them, what are their question,
what are they needs? Maybe a lot
of you here know about design
thinking or human centered
design. And it's just that it's
like, Who is the person who's
listening to you? Why do they
find you valuable? What are
their stuff they need? And maybe
can you serve them? So this is
why we ended up doing lupa, for
example, that that app for
Spanish learners, we knew that
they were listening to Radio
Ambulante because they wanted to
learn Spanish. So we made it
easier. A and at the same time,
we made it profitable,
collaborate, but then no, two
Welcome to helping hands. Like
that's why we ask people, you
have great ideas, we we cannot
come up with new ideas every
week alone. So let us know what
kind of stories would you like
us to tell? And like just
inviting them and knowing and
making making them know, that
you're open to that makes a huge
difference. And finally get the
data use surveys. We did a
survey every year. We call
people within person meetings
with people understanding Yes,
like, how can we serve you serve
you better? Share your
expertise. And this is what I
was saying about being
reciprocal online. Like, give,
give give like this is, to me
the spirit of the internet is
Share, share, share, because and
this is super hippie, I'm sorry.
But I think when you share in a
network, it comes back somehow,
right? If you're actually part
of a network, so
like, for three years, we were
giving, giving giving to the
community. We were not asking
for money, all the specific
occasions like giving Tuesday
like specific days, but we were
mostly giving and when we felt
ready to Install the membership
program immediately. It's sorry
coming in. And I am aware, I'm
aware that it's very hard to
give three years a if you're not
getting back, if you don't have
other revenue streams, we had
the privilege of having to
grants and your budget, you get
the concept like it's you're in
a network, you have give, and
you receive, you give you
receive, respect people's
attention, because there's a lot
of noise out there. And I think
this is a, you know, this is a
huge problem of the internet.
Right now we're saturated,
saturated with information, our
attention span is limited. So
let's do things that stand out
and that are valuable to people
and that feel useful and
meaningful and not, let's just
not to make more noise.
recognizer advanced sports, like
your blind spots, because many
times A, we are so narrow minded
with the way we see the world,
that we forget that there are
many things that we just don't
know that we don't do, right.
And we should be humble and ask
like, Hey, how can I get better.
So this is ways in which we
share our expertise, we did a
lot of workshops, like a like in
which we taught otter is how to
do a good interview for radio,
or in which we, in in a website
with greatest whatever I'm
planting, which is free
resources for those who want to
produce stories, or we create a
newsletter in which we were, we
were recommending every week,
things that were inspiring us
online. So other podcasts, you
see videos, stories, so we were
all the time, which is sharing,
sharing, sharing, this one to
meet super important and it's
related to the first part of the
of this talk in which you should
develop rituals and routines.
Because a I think networks and
this is a quote from Guido
Caldarelli networks, right to
explain how a set of isolated
elements are transformed to a
pattern of interactions into
groups and communities. And what
are those interactions, what's
the pattern of interactions that
you can facilitate? So a group
is created, right? You have a
network, maybe some people are
interested in what you're
interested. But that doesn't
mean that there is a group, and
the community is formed, when
those interactions become
regular, become constant. And
they, they have a pattern,
right? So gather meaningfully a
constant, and make it
unpredictable. And sometimes we
feel that, yes, to talk to
people or to get together,
that's to ask me anything, or
just let's do Twitter space, and
then you just get stuck in those
kinds of platforms. And there's
much, there are many more ways
to get together. And if you're
not creative, people will just
start seeing it as noise and
repetitive. So you need to
create refreshing ways of
gathering meaningfully. There's
a great book, that it's called
The Art of Gathering that I
recommend, if you're planning to
learn more about this. So this
is an example we publish a story
about a girl who was kidnapped,
kidnapped in Latin America. And
then we just asked people, but
the story was about the family
album of the family who were
trying to find her in the in the
story. And then people started
sending pictures of their own
family albums, which was great.
So it was a way to connect
people around the issue of at
episode a listening clubs. That
is another way. This is a
virtual club, just like just
expand the repertoire of of
rituals that you do to connect
people set rules to preserve
trust, which is essential. If
people don't trust those in the
group. They won't participate.
So you need to create a code of
conduct moderated with data for
the listening clubs. We did that
for every space online that we
had be a connector. It's not
only that you connect with your
listeners, but you connect
listeners among each other and
see your community as a team. So
these are pictures of the listen
to Bob's these are like these
are not strangers to us to us.
These listeners are part of
Radio Ambulante, and we see the
collective
expertise and knowledge as our
knowledge. Choose the right
platform. And this is key try to
only tour channels because if
you devote all your engagement
work to Instagram, Twitter to
Facebook, once they change the
rules, then you're screwed. So
you need to own your channels.
So have a mailing list for
example, there's a phone
numbers, that helps a lot. Make
it horizontal, like how can you
connect with people, not
inaccurate article way, but more
like, at the same level, and
explore sometimes it's great to
do it online. But sometimes it's
great just to do it offline. In
Radio Ambulante's case we had
our own channel. So this is the
podcast feed, we publish our
episodes and people like this is
something that we own. It's an
error RSS that we own, or a
WhatsApp, WhatsApp, we had a
huge lease of like 3000, almost
4000 listeners, a WhatsApp
didn't allow us to create like
broadcast lists, we took all
those numbers. And those
numbers, phone numbers are ours.
It's they're not of WhatsApp. So
that gave us an ability to react
against a change of rules. But
we still use the app invoice we
like last year, we still are
using the app in which in ways
that were useful. And this is a
newsletter, which is an also a
list that you use, as a media
that you use that you own sorry.
And finally make it look unique.
Like the visuals and the style.
They say a lot about who you
are, even before people start
reading you're listening to you.
So these are illustrations for
different episodes of Biollante
that are made by artists in the
region. And his original
original artwork that sends out
in social media. We had this
design team a yes, that made it
look unique. And that is very
important if you really want to
stand out. And finally enjoy.
Because I think that social,
like the engagement thing, it's
about getting together in
creative ways. And joy is a big
part of it. If it's boring,
unfortunately, there are many
boring instances in people
lives. So you just have to make
fun. And some useful frameworks.
This is a this is a membership
guide of a membership portal
project, which was a project a
New York University and they
studied how people become become
members like how an individual
they is just becoming aware of
five grand then becomes a really
huge engage ambassadors the
grant. So that is a useful
framework that you could study
is a book called Get Together,
which is also like a guidebook
to understand different
communities, and how can you
create or replicate that the
things that they that they found
out there. And also this one,
it's super tight to me was very,
a orienting. It's called the
Community Campus, which divides
the community building process
into three sections that are
divided in themes that are very,
very useful to. So that's it.
From me a thank you so much for
listening, and I will be happy
to answer questions. And yeah,
and just to talk. Thank you. I
will stop sharing. Thank you,
Heather Hendershot: Jorge. We're
all muted. So I think other
people are applauding, but maybe
can only hear me. Um, so yeah,
let's open up to questions. We
have 20 minutes or so for
discussion who would like to
kick us off? I think Tomás had
his hand up there first.
Tomás Guarna: Great. Thank you
for a fantastic talk. And I
especially interested in the
pump that you mentioned, your
revenue strategies and how you
monetize how you made it party
sustainable, which I think is
super interesting. And I was
wondering on I understand that
this is kind of the most
pressing problem for independent
media. And I was wondering if
you could share some advice you
would give to to others similar
products or interesting
monetizing their platform their
their medium, I might not make
it sustainable.
Jorge Caraballo: Yes, yes. I
think that it at the like the
bottom line to me, but you know,
like to to someone with a
hammer, everything is a nail and
to me that I'm thinking about
communities. To me, the bottom
line is to have a community that
actually it's actually invested
in what you do. So for example,
I am part of a community in
Colombia that is led by this
woman who's publishing content
about how can we be more
friendly and loving with the
earth right how can we be more
calm? of what we're doing to the
earth. And she has been
publishing in a blog for like 10
years. And like, two years ago,
she was like, hey, if I if I, if
I want to keep doing this, but I
cannot do it without your
support. So she created this
Patreon. And hundreds, maybe
1000s of people are part of that
community, and allow her to do
that. But they they are, they
are so engaged. Because she has
been constant. She has been
generous, she's clever, she's
insightful. She's what she
publishes useful, it has changed
our lives, it makes us feel part
of, of something that is larger
than ourselves. It's it, it
connects like she is a referent
of the change that we want to
make. And when you become that,
when you're if you're an
independent media, if your
mission is very clear, and what
you're doing, it's really
useful. And you are effective,
inviting people to follow your
work to make it better, if
you're listening to them, and
ask them, hey, what you need,
and how can I help you, when you
get to the point in which the
community is large enough, and
it's eventually it will
eventually happen, then you can
say, okay, like, this is what we
have, we're together, we're part
of this, you are connected to
each other, because we're doing
this work. If we want to keep
doing this together, we need, we
need your support, and your
financial support. And it's
completely okay to say that
openly. And people respond in
ways that surprise you like,
positive voice that surprised
you. So my advice is, is that is
like, give, be useful, listen
back, a serve to the needs of
the people and make your purpose
super clear. So people feel that
you are at fascination that is
your mission. And that is their
mission too.
Tomás Guarna: Is it already if I
do a small follow up question.
Alright, so thank you. Thank you
for that particular it seems
really interesting. And it's
true that once a community gets
a certain size, then it is
there, you can find a slice that
is willing to fund your right.
But I wonder if, if, if How do
you like if you've been given
your community free content for
a while? Why would they expect
to pay you which is what I see a
lot of content creators grab,
grab grapple with, right? Like
how do you communicate to them
that your work needs to be
funded in a in a situation where
there's so much content is
available for free, right?
Jorge Caraballo: So I recommend
you to check and study episode,
this is something that you're
you're trying to do go and with
the membership guide. And it's
part of the membership portal
project, it was their final
project. So the membership
puzzle project is still there,
but a in a new way. But there's
something called the membership
guide that they produced last
year. And they dissected a lot
of organizations that have been
in that exact situation like how
we how do we do how we create
membership, like how can we make
people support us. And they have
a lot of cases, which are super,
super interesting. But I just
want to highlight something that
they say, and one of the reasons
why people become members is not
because of the content, but
because of the community.
Because if you if you connect a
community, and then people will
feel that if you're not there,
the community will not be there.
And they don't want that loss.
They don't want to lose that
community. Because the community
is where it's giving a lot of
value to their lives. So
somehow, if creating the
community is at the same time
creating the base for your
sustainability, because the
community is what people value
and they will pay to be part of
that community. Great, thank
you. So yes, and that's the
membership. Yes, that's the
membership guide, and we put in
the chat. Thank you.
Ámbar Reyes: Oh, good. Yeah, I
saw that question. Thank you,
Andrew. Next we have Ámbar.
Thank you, Heather. Thank you,
Jorge, for these amazing stuff I
was especially interested in
when you were talking about like
making this story growth and
started telling us on open in
that process. But I was
wondering how did you choose
which specific like episodes or
themes to use for your
community? engagement in social
media, because I'm assuming that
not all episodes, were, you
know, like you continue using
it. So yeah,
Jorge Caraballo: yeah,
definitely, there are some
episodes like political episodes
that are just like, No, there's
not, there's not no human. It's
harder to identify with. So the
episodes that that we use for
this kind of exercises were
those episodes in which you as,
in which the universal
experience of the character was
easier to see was, was easy to
identify. So migration, for
example, or a your connection to
a city, your, your relationship
with your with it with an
object, like a precious object
in your family, things that
you're like, Oh, yes, I get
this, I get this, I get this, I
have that, like, like, I can
translate that into my life
super easily. But those episodes
that were more focused on hyper
specific things of the reality
of Latin America, a, they were
harder to translate it to this
kind of engagement. But yes,
like, it's human experience and
the universal like, universal,
universal experience.
Ámbar Reyes: Thank you.
Heather Hendershot: Thank you.
Um, I was wondering if you
could, you talked about so many
successful engagement
strategies? Um, well, first, I
want to say I'm super impressed
by your optimism about the
internet. And there's a moment
where you actually said the
internet is for listening. And I
was like, that's great, because
of course, we've all had sort of
the opposite experience, and
especially with with Twitter,
right, and things can can go
awry. And, you know, I just
wonder if you could talk about
some of your engagement
strategies that maybe failed, or
were less strong. And you know,
what you learn from that for
going forward?
Jorge Caraballo: Oh, yes. Many
of them. Many, many, many, like
many of engagement prompts had
see responses, five responses,
a. And I think that one thing
that we learned, after many
failures is that you can not ask
people to think a lot like to
reflect a lot before starting
typing and started thinking
about their interaction or their
intervention. So many questions
felt, like, paper questions. And
people won't, like stop their
social media feed, to write down
homework, they just don't want
that. They just want to have
fun, or they just want to go to
a place in their mind, which is
not the place in their mind that
they have to go to write down a
thesis, right? So it needs to be
closer to their heart, it needs
to be a need to be in that sweet
spot of emotionally, emotions
and argument, a, and that is
very hard to craft into a
prompt. So many of the crowns
were felt like very mental make
very rational. And people just
ignore that completely. So in
many of the stories in some of
the stories, we asked people to
give opinions that they were not
interested in thinking about the
complexity of the situation in
their own lives. And because
very, because the prompt is
difficult, very few responses
happen. And because very few
responses happen, less people
said, and at the end, it's just
buried in the feed. So that's
something right, that we learn
about, about how to craft
prompts. A, and how can you be
How can you be creative and
meaningful at the same time? At
the beginning of the pandemic,
we did an exercise that were
that was relatively frivolous,
super, like, it was? Yes, it was
stupid. [...] seen as stupid.
But it worked. A and it was
like, we started asking people
when we were locked down all
around the world. We wanted to
understand how are they
perceiving the world? So we
focus on a sense every week, a
different sense every week. So
we started asking people, show
us what you're seeing. A send us
a picture of what you're seeing
in that first window on your
right hand. And then hundreds of
things and they send us. I don't
remember which set like all of
the senses, but every sense had
a different prompt, and it
worked. And what did what what
happened? What, what we were
trying to do is to understand
the community as a body as a
single body with 1000s of eyes,
each listener was an eye, each
listener was like a nose flavor,
what what did you What was the
last thing that you read in this
pandemic, or before the pandemic
started something like that. So
we were thinking about the
community as a as a huge system
as a huge body. And I say this,
this was a successful case. But
I say this, because what you
want is to go to the senses go
to the sensual, before, before
of the mind, of course, some
topics are good to think about
and to, like, be rational, and
to have some conversations, it's
very hard to have that. By the
way, you go to what you're
feeling. And when you touch that
in people, people immediately
start participating. So the
sweet spot between the sensual
and the rational, it's something
that we learned after many
failures.
Ámbar Reyes: Thank you. Um, do
we have any other questions? We
I have one more? Oh, Andrew.
Yes. Yes,
Andrew Whitacre: Thank you so
much for this has been
wonderful. You really got me
thinking about reminding me of
an experience that I had, when
you talked about the listening
groups. So this was several
years ago, I taught a podcasting
class. And one of the things I
was worried about was the
selections that I had for for
listening, where students can
engage with them. So during
MIT's January, sort of period
where you can teach whatever
class if you want, I invited
people to come listen to the
things I was going to use in the
semester long class. And that
was the first time I'd been in a
room with people sitting around
the table, and a speaker in the
center, all listening to the
same thing at the same time. And
I realized that, gosh, like 99%
of the time that we're consuming
media, whether it's in a movie
theater at a concert hall,
televisions, in our own house,
everything we're just we're
sitting staring at the same
thing in the same direction. As
opposed to those rooms, where
you're listening to something
and you're sitting around,
you're watching each other react
to the same things and sort of
getting a read of each other's
faces. I guess my question was,
you guys also did that over
zoom? Is that right?
Jorge Caraballo: Yes.
Andrew Whitacre: Can you did
people have the same experience
during those groups over zoom,
like maybe to through a computer
screen as they did when they
were listening in person
together?
I think I think yes, but it's
harder. And of course, there are
many things that you cannot
read. In a, like in a in a
screen, because when you're when
you're in a room in a round
table, as you say, watching each
other you can feel the energy if
you can, you can feel the
attention of the room, you can
feel the tension, you can feel
the what's flowing, right, if
you become like a single entity,
and and when someone is anxious
when someone is a feeling
nervous, because speaking up
about something that it's hard
to process, there are many
things that you read in the
body. In some, it's easier, I
think, just to be a little bit
distant. But overall, the
quality of the conversation I
think was was very good in some
so it was less emotional. It was
less emotional. But it was good.
Like, it was it was insightful.
It was diverse. It gave new
ideas. Sure. Like, one of the
things that sometimes we did
listening clubs for stories
before publishing them, to see
if there were things that were
not clear that we're not that
were that could be improved. And
that was great in person or in
zoom like that worked either
way. But I think that when you
get in a room with strangers,
when it's like in soon, they're
listening clubs where 100 300
people there in a in a in a room
were 12 to 15 people. So there's
kind of like there is more
vulnerability there. Right?
There's more a it's more
fragile. And and that's
something that you cannot
replicate digitally.
Ámbar Reyes: I think we will.
We've got one last question I
want to take from the attendees
who aren't in the the panelist
side of it. Um, this is from
Aguinaldo Melo, who asked how do
you see podcasts serving as a
medium to enable storytelling?
And how do you think we can
promote a similar kind of
storytelling them on other
mediums? This is a question of
the medium or the message?
Jorge Caraballo: That's the
question. I think that podcasts
has had, they have its own
thing. It's very, like, we can
go here into what makes podcasts
different from radio, I think
that it's mostly the same, but
there's a huge difference, which
is that you know, who's
listening to you. And because
you know, who's listening to
you, there is there's a
reciprocal relationship. And
there, there is a connection
that you cannot have on radio,
of course, a radio there were,
you knew that were there were
like groups of people listening
to you, you could know where
you're a average listener, or
they could send you things,
letters, whatever. But in
podcasts, there's this because
we're, it's a digital medium,
you have data on who's listening
to you where a when the
attention is dropping, you know,
you have many data points that
inform you about who's on the
other side at the same time,
like they can just read, you can
calculate your reviews,
essential emails. So that
ability to know who's on the
other side gives you if you're,
if you're paying attention, or
shapes, if you're paying
attention the way you talk to
that person, right? So I think
that podcast, good podcast, feel
so close to you, because they
know who you are, because
they're seeing you, right?
Almost in real time. Now, in
real time, whether it's data is
so fresh, that they know,
they're and they know how to
talk to you and you feel that
the podcast you love or talking
to you, not to people, similar
to you, but to you. And I cannot
emphasize that enough. So I
think that this is about the
medium, of course, that enables
the storytelling feel so close.
But I think that I think it's
possible to replicate that or
that that could be translated to
other medium digital mediums,
right. But I don't know if
that's the case in the other
mediums. So if as a journalist
that has experimented in
magazines, in a video
documentaries in radio, and
podcast, I like the one in which
I see higher engagement, much
higher engagement is in
podcasts.
Ámbar Reyes: That is really
interesting. I'm really glad
that we got into some issues
about medium specificity at the
end there those great I think
that Wade Roush, who's in our
attendee pool, might summarize
things the best for us to close
out he said, fantastic sessions,
so inspirational for those of us
working to build community and
podcasting, congrats, Jorge, and
enjoy the rest of your year at
Harvard, I would echo that.
Thank you so much. And I'm just
going to say one more thing,
just put in a little plug for
next week's colloquium series,
we have Hillary Chute speaking
from Northeastern, and she's
going to be talking about Maus.
And I'll just add that, you
know, we arranged this maybe
almost two months ago, um, she
said her project was about the,
you know, continuing relevance
of Maus and she was sort of
asking like, you still feel like
it's relevant. And I was like,
Oh, absolutely. And of course,
this was before the recent
crisis and controversy around
Maus in Tennessee, so it's a
good it's going to be terrific,
terrific talk. So I will see all
the grad students there, and I
hope to see many of our other
attendees there as well. Thank
you again, Jorge. And good night
to everyone.
Jorge Caraballo: Hey, thank you
so much. Bye bye.